hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast quantitative label-free
imaging and its many applications
presented by dr. Peter O'Toole a
director of the bioscience technology
facility head of imaging the cytometry
in the Department of Biology
in University of York and dr. Rakesh
Suman a biological application scientist
at Fay's focused
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth
labyrinths is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen and our speakers
will respond to your questions via email
if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing this presentation just click on
the ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education credit
credit tab that's located on the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process for obtaining
your credits please join me now in
welcoming our presenters dr. Peter
O'Toole and dr. Rakesh Suman I will now
turn the presentation over to them
welcome gentlemen Susie thank you very
much for that introduction it's very
kind of you
so yes I'm Peter O'Toole and I'm Rakesh
Suman
okay so actually you can see it's a
joint talk the case used to work for me
probably here at York before moving on
to become an application specialist at
Pace pocus but actually we gonna be
talking about a lot of the work he
actually started here as a postdoc in
the early days before I move off at
first light actually I just like to
introduce my team who aren't here
to present with us but I'm actually
really important the blue guys that so
people in blue here are by core staff
they they work it within the facility as
a service provision but I've been very
instrumental in a lot of these
developmental work especially John
Morrison who was a pivotal really the
very start the inception of the worker
we'll be talking about and then in
blackness later postdocs including
Rakesh who actually is still a visiting
scientist in my lab here at York and
part of that that team I'm still seeing
very much as a team itself so to give
you some idea I'd like to introduce a
bit about us to give you some context as
to where we're going and why are
interesting label-free microscopy so I
actually work at at University of York
the Department of Biology which is a
multi-disciplined department it actually
has a whole tranche of different
biologists here working for us yeah
we've got the infectious ones they're
dead they're be the immunologists okay
we've got the users and then people who
come to use Mike's case it really bug us
there'd be the microbiologists or well
then the fun guys so you can see any C's
branching out but that would be with the
plant biologists and the ones that are
developing still maybe they're seldom
developmental biologists you can see
I've got a plan for all of these but I
know how time is limited but the key
thing is here is the applications we
look for are serving a vast array of
different biological applications we not
really focused just on cancer just on
immunology we're looking across the
broad Church of biological applications
critically the imaging lab it's actually
part of the bioscience technology
facility which I'm very grateful to
actually there'd be director of but I
also have my own lab which is the
imaging a cytometry luck
there's also the genomics the
bioinformatics protein production
molecular interactions metabolomic sand
proteomics labs but you'll notice
actually my previous director made this
uh I can wait call it this visual thing
on the right we can't call it a logo or
anything information I can't type
but you'll notice he put imaging in
cytometry at the top and I thought that
was quite clever I thought that he
obviously likes me a lot
or he's meaning something can actually I
thought deep and I realized why imaging
this cytometry is at the top because I
would argue microscopy is one of the lis
techniques out there and this is why
genomics we have a great genomics
facility genomics as you know for the
last war I don't know 17 18 years we
know that human genome is an awesome and
really powerful tool but ultimately if
you go even just look at the RNA that is
being transcribed it doesn't tell you
altima leave that the protein has been
transcribed so at which point even
though the RNA is present it doesn't
mean the protein it's actually going to
do anything that it's functional is
present so genomics can only take us so
far before it comes up against a brick
wall and becomes a bit limited but I've
got my metabolism proteomics lab and
they say happy don't worry we can take
your tissue we can take yourselves
obviously not my cells or Katie's own
cells but cells that we working with
that be inappropriate and we can take
those cells and we can find in
identifying what proteins have been
transferred what proteins are physically
in that cell which is great so now I
know the protein has been transcribed
but doesn't tell us if the protein is
folded correctly it doesn't tell us if
it's localized to a functional unit it
doesn't tell us if the code practice the
code proteins have come together to form
a functional complex
so even proteomics runs up against a
similar brick wall and becomes limited
but hey as a biochemist we have the
molecular interactions lab they can
actually now with a protein production
up they can make lots of this protein
and we can get it in our qubit and in
that qubit we can do a biochemical
analysis we can look at our I know
SPRs we can do after imagery sort of die
krauser all different types of micro
colorimetry we can look at enthalpies
associated with these we can look at on
operates we can look at enzymatic
activities we can look at all that
biochemical biophysical information but
ultimately
it's in the cuvette which isn't really
related to real-life scenarios it's a
great tool it's essential but what we
really need to do you see that protein
inside the living cell and that's what
we can do in microscopy we can now see
the protein has been transcribed we can
see it in the cell we can see where it's
localized to the cell and then if we do
our flip flap flip flap and flim there's
an awful lot of four-letter F words
associated fluorescence microscopy if
you can think of any other four letter F
words maybe not don't don't don't not
now but critically not only can we see
the proteins we can do and perhaps our
fret we can look out protein protein
interactions we can look at our dynamics
we can do a biochemical biophysical
studies of the protein inside the living
cell which is why microscopy is the best
technique out there for any biologist
now obviously I'm kind of half joking
about this I'll come to this slide right
at the end but but only half joking
obviously the Diploma in microscopy are
usually limited to the number of cells
you can look at which is don't forget I
am a Saitama triste as well which is my
cytometry who gives us those we
statistical numbers and statistical
relevance which i think is really
important itself so the lab itself isn't
just a cool facility we also do a lot of
developmental research we're an
international hub for a large African
project we do a lot of be testing for
commercial companies international
reference sites we took a bit circuit
but - but the one area I want to
concentrate on today is typography
label-free imaging and that's we've
really been there the inception of
typography for life cell science years
ago probably 88 2010 I think we started
to get involved with this and this is
for label-free imaging they might ask
yourself we can do this but what's so
different about label-free imaging well
arguably it's less invasive which is
which is important fewer fewer
perturbations and it's quantitative
which enables do live cell imaging but
we can do live cell imaging with
fluorescent tights we can label them and
see them but that may cause
perturbations so
are humans we don't candidly similar
shirts by coincidence uh that always
copy copying me I'm not quite sure which
but we have very wavy shirts
okay we can eat and drink and walk and
talk but we are labeled because we are
wearing clothes now we can still eat and
drink and walk and talk if we were
unlabeled maybe don't think about that
for too long and if you are thinking
about that please be looking at Mukesh
he's funny better than I am when he's
label free maybe not I don't know
regardless as subtle behaviors would be
different if we were laden free now when
we look at life selves when we do a
fluorescence imaging the cells are weak
we want to go through cell cycle and
divide we presume that the cells are
happy because they can go on to grow and
divide and proliferate but it's those
subtle behaviors that we may have
perturbed that we will miss we won't
realize that so if we can minimize the
neater label we can remove it altogether
we get closer to the true life scenario
and that's why I feel that like the
label printing is really important so
typography is a form of quantitative
phase imaging and it can take your
normal image as you can see here and it
can convert it into a high contrast
image which looks very similar to a
fluorescence image but isn't present
it's a quantitative phase image from a
label or something that has not been
labeled with any stains what so ever and
that's important and this next movie
shows something quite quite important if
you look at the image you can see on the
screen at the moment you can see three
concentric circles at the bottom right
of this so part of the very bottom one
has been exposed three times to
different to UV light I know you v's
never ideal but still plenty people
Dewhurst and Dappy especially hurts for
lifestyle tracking within there there's
better you can go and use that five guys
if you do that going to use
in the red but nonetheless it's still
commonly used and any light is going to
potentially cause perturbation to the
sample so that bottom circle has been
irradiated once the second circle up
that area's been irradiated twice and
just off slightly up into the left it's
been irradiated three times the rest of
the images have not seen any
fluorescence illumination itself and so
if we watch this movie you'll see how
the cells dying after one who the ones
that have been exposed total or three
times and you'll see if twice they start
to die and slow down third they're a bit
slower but the population that hasn't
been touched it's completely undisturbed
at that point so if we just look at the
video now
you
okay so hopefully you saw what we were
talking about at that point so how do we
get this data to start with I think
that's always a good question with it
and this is how we get our quantitative
phasing daddy
mukeshji come on you're the expert at
this okay so what we're generating here
is a quantitative phase image a way of
getting that high contrast from a label
free image there's lots of methods out
there or quantitative phase imaging but
on the lives though with the product
from Facebook we use a method called
typography and what this essentially
does is calculate the phase delay as the
light passes through the cell so you can
see in the bottom right in the cartoon
light weight B is becoming delay
compared to light weight Bay and in a
nutshell the video of the phase today
the brighter the pixel value in the
image to lower the phase today the pixel
value in your image what's important is
that this phase delay is dependent on
physical properties of the cell
both the thickness and the refractive
index can cause a phase delay and
therefore we see as we go on through the
seminar we can use this page today to
quantitate genuine metrics such as dry
mass optical volume and thickness of the
cell okay but it is quite neat if we
look actually what happens to this we
pass a very low intensity event laser
beam through the specimen on the right
you'll see we get a series of different
diffracted light pattern images so the
camera is looking directly at the laser
beam which means you the intensity of
light has to be attenuated has to be
decreased to really low power so this
really is pretty much shining like is
negligible especially out in the far red
and that's one of the great things about
a lot of the quantitative phase imaging
techniques that are out there
it enables us to do this then once we've
got those images we can move it forward
and we can take those final images take
it through the appropriate transport
through the algorithm to give us a
quantitative face image which is what
you see over on the right of your screen
at the moment for that
users quantitative information we did in
there and she go on Rakesh you two
contrasting me okay so what we're
looking at on this slide is how you can
start to turn those images into metrics
so we do that by comparing what contrast
again from a quantitative phase image
compared to conventional label-free
imaging technology so we have the same
sample here the same line profit across
the same three cells and it's only when
you start looking at the line profile
the gray values you can see that it's
only with the quantitative base image
that you see these three distinct peaks
one for each cell to try and get that
same information from the face contrast
so do see image is very difficult you
have the same amount of grade level in
the DRC image as you do inside the cell
ID to do in the background alone and
also the phase contrast image you have
these handle artifacts which are
primitive features within the stuff so
it's quite interesting every time I show
this image for the first time to new
users or potential customers they tell
me is that a freshness image and it's
good reason because when we look at the
same sample staying with dresses we can
see we have the same level of contrast
as a freshness image but we're
generating this without the use of any
labels or any high lumination power to
excite the fluorophore sticks that those
labels yes are you lumen a ting but the
critical thing for me is that my users
can do their lifestyle imaging now but
they can now actually segment their
cells and with these it's not easy
otherwise so we can take our areas of
high competency and actually sake men
with cells themselves so we can do our
quantitative analysis on such fields of
view itself I'm actually we can then
obviously not just take any reach we can
repeat taking an image and then take a
lot everybody turn another way we've
done another image so we can do our
time-lapse for this so in this case
actual team actually the previous takes
with mind this is your Dexter so I'm
gonna that York is actually home of many
things including different
confectionaries so actually I'm gonna
take
right well we can't talk you through
this slide okay so what you gotta say
next is you're gonna say a video showing
describe 3si and here we segmented and
track every single cell within the
scratch so just enjoy this next video
you
okay hopefully you got that sorry Jonah
Drake as well thank you pleasure what
was really good it's not just the
ability to time-lapse the image itself
it's also the ability to get
quantitative information out of that and
that's a key difference again that
compared to di C or face contrast is we
can now get measurements that are you
need to quantitative phase imaging
processes so of course we can look at
cell count we could look at area
perimeter length circularity but we can
now get granularity we can look at the
mass the volume the thickness bits of
information quantitative phase
information that it's completely normal
to qpi techniques and that's really
enabling us are we going to show you
just mind blank then we can start to
pick up new phenotypes that we didn't
know existed before but putting time to
this and getting the kinetic data really
big longitudinal studies we can look at
the speeds news placements and
velocities how they interact with other
cells and the underling index and what
really struck us is that every cell
tells a different story
and that's been a huge thing for me
certainly at York is to look at that as
a flow cytometry you know we look at
single-cell analysis and from that
single cell analysis we quite often look
at the population and we look at the
medians and look at this but I can still
go back to the individual that part of
the flow cytometer
and now we haven't to think about our
imaging in exactly the same way as you
go through this and actually it was this
movie that I will show you next that
actually shows this in really good
detail so if I just quickly play this
video and talk you through what's
happening on this slide
so let's look at a whole big field of
view that we can look at what we'll do
now is zoom in just now using the red
box to highlight what we're looking at
in the top left is a microglial cell in
the middle is a cell on a bit of debris
that's going to get brighter and
brighter and brighter cuz it's a popped
otic and just the left of that isn't
dead cell we're now gonna see that
bright cell pop lose the intensity in
this cell at the top can swoop down and
eat that sell off that bit of debris
soon as it's done that it will notice
his helmet was at nine o'clock and he's
going to eat that in entirety become a
very large cell indeed ah fat boy that's
there now the yellow box is what we'll
come to next that's great
let's show the next bit
yellow box is a cell just below the
center is abouts divided into two we now
have two identical cells to sell on the
Left gets the munchies if the hungry
sister and or shoot-off starting to eat
every bit of apoptotic material it can
see system on the right just below the
air bubble is doing nothing sit on there
shoots off to the left again and go
through there needs to be even more
debris just off screen comes back and
there's a lot more to the north - atchoo
off to the north eating even more now
this sound below appears to have done
nothing but he has it's been getting
bigger and bigger and bigger up until
the point that it divides again itself
and then you have the same won't happen
again
how cool was that that is just awesome
that that Selma went off that that you
had two doors ourselves calm sisters
because they are sisters that were meant
to be identical but obviously had
asymmetric division we're very
difference in their behaviors and the
selling of got the munchies we actually
gave a name to we give ourselves names
because it kind of is identified with
them and we call me sell dyson that we
called it dyson for several reasons
first thing i appreciate and this is an
international audience we'll have people
around the world i don't know what time
it is where you are at the moment but
morning afternoon evening can you some
coffee if it's the middle of the night
hey hey a copy can be good become it die
someday because Dyson it's an example of
British engineering hey see we do do
something useful every now and then it's
elegant and yet simple bit like a shirts
really elegant
doesn't matter efficient inquire ok and
Dyson is I would say a well leader ok
bed so our contribution ISA
yeah vacuum cleaners however for anyone
watching mister it's into your
microscopes I would like to point out to
any microscopy manufacturer that there's
more vacuum cleaners in the world than
the bar microscopes pay to go with fritz
see we do do something useful every now
and then so this now is going to show
dice a day we just look at this still
for a moment you can see at the top of
the image there's a cell coming down
from about twelve quarters to the left
with rubber clock coming down you can
see the new right there's lots of a pop
talking material on that new right
Dyson is going to come in from the
bottom right so if I just play that
video for you now coming from the right
clean up the up top material and
disappear off if you look closely at the
new right if you've got the resolution
on your monitors you can see cleanly off
the new right take it up and go down if
you look at the
bottom you'll see a neuritis about to
divide you'll see the chromosomes align
and divided over time it's pretty cool
so that was a a really cool movie
watching dice in itself and I was
telling I think he was actually born in
York here so Michael actually we had
chocolate named after him to to me Bart
they go he gets hungry these funny
afternoon nonetheless the key thing is
watching one sound tells us very little
it's fascinating we wonder what's going
on but we need lots of cells to make me
statistically relevant and that's what's
great now to do the type of graphic
method we have here we can look at huge
fields of view I think this was three
millimeters by three millimeters in this
particular instance and from that we can
then also take our individual time
tracks for each cell and see how they
all behave within that mass population
just like play cytometry but we time and
time-lapse movies actually watch the
faithful cells which is when we came
across a next sound record which was
call you saying bond now you saying Bob
because he too is a world leader now I
don't like to be beaten and I'm going to
race Usain Bolt so we thought it'd be a
good idea here to actually give him some
drugs doping but not to speed him up
critically to slow him down and all his
cohorts within that population of course
being a true scientist
we will now compare that against a
control sample have had no drugs
whatsoever do the race what should
happen Usain Bolt's still won the race
so actually we did lots and lots of time
tracks watched on the cells and then we
lot heed their speed against time and we
can see here after 24 hours yeah they
seem to be slow to beat so the magenta
ones are the ones that are b-tree to be
drugs the control samples the square
boxes that are gray are the controls and
you can see here that the treated cells
in magenta have all been slowed down on
average but if you look at 48 hours to
pass t-cell happens to be the magenta so
after 72 hours to pass t-cell by some
way is Usain Bolt
that magenta cell is really important
you see just an outlier
this shouldn't be outliers this is a
Salman
differently I think I think why is it
behaving differently to the rest of
population if this is a chemotherapy
drug
you know these drugs working really well
it's affecting 99 percent of the self
but 1 percent of the cell it doesn't
react with it or behave opposite to what
you wanted to do so it's that 1% that
else are killing us not the 99 percent
they're effective
so it's out like it's actually really
really important and I think I've just
called Usain Bolt and murderer at the
same time if it doesn't get done for
drugs rule having won something else as
well
so why was that cell difference well I
can see now that he's different
okay so I've got that in my single dope
lots of play cytometry type analysis but
critically I can now add new metrics to
it I can see if he was a bigger or
slower cell and that's important but
because now I can see who's skinnier or
who's bound up I gotta get an idea the
structure of the cell you know easiest
are show yourself why so many sounds -
ok we can see because you can look at
the mass of the cell relates relates to
the intensity we can see if he packs
more proteins but all protein patty no
easy always you're more diffused
compared to others we can get all these
unique phase metrics which can help us
understand human that we can phenotype
give him a different phenotype compared
to the other cells and so we can put all
those metrics who are looking to to each
and individual single cell look at the
population would go back to senior cell
but my bread and butter is
fluorescence microscopy and as good as
quantitative phase imaging is we still
sometimes need to see more actually
sometimes we need to see a lot more
promise and fluorescence gives us that
because what I can't tell you is how
much of any specific protein between
that cell or cell population itself and
that's really important but of course
it's a microscope so we're good on the
qpi system critically we can now
correlate these with fluorescence
microscope images so we can take a
quantitative phase image and then
overlaid in citrine with the
fluorescence image this is actually work
the vacations working on in the lab when
it was working with us
and trying to identify my cleaner from
astrocytes to neutrons and we could do
our assay and then at the end of our
time lapse I label free image we could
stop the experiment and do our endpoint
assay adding the fluorescence molecules
to it so we can do that as an endpoint
well actually that's not always what you
want to do sometimes you need for
essence at the same time and we'll look
at that later
so the question this is what it looks
like now it's a lot better than the
heats moments and sesame matter so some
eight years ago more system and I won't
bore you with all the hard way because
this is an educational seminar at the
end of educational lecture at the end so
this is just a picture of the lifestyle
you can learn a lot more about this by
going to the face focused website but
what I do want to talk about is what we
can do with the images and we've got
that high contrast image that Peters
talked about but I want to show you next
how you can take the high contrast image
perform that segmentation that tracking
and turning it into metrics because at
the end what we want to do we need the
numbers to describe what's happening in
those videos we want that beautiful
nature paper and we need to quantify we
can't just put in a video anymore and
say this looks great
sells a movie we need to be able to
quantify so in the next few slides I'm
showing you some of the applications and
how we can quantify so here we have an
example of a handful of applications for
the live site and it's not exhaustive
but I'll start here with this our debt
and liberation asset so let's focus on
an individual cell to start with what we
can do we can track that cell throughout
the time and that's we can watch the
cell divide we can then track a daughter
cell up until the next division event
and we can see what's happening to that
cell we can quantify it in the top graph
here is the mean thickness so we see at
the point of mitosis the cell becomes
very round and very thick at the point
by Thomas's then the daughter cells
divide the sadly boys have two daughter
cells which have a very large thickness
trap cell cycle so is that that just
looking at that it's just over two and a
half and coming up to around five yes
we're seeing here is a drying mass of
the cells and what we see at the start
of the cell cycle to the end of the cell
cycle we haven't done bleep up the dry
mass of the cell until then we reach
their next point which is mitosis again
and what you can see is why if you do
zoom into cells you can start to
identify the individual stages of
mitosis so we can do at the the
chromosome alignment on the mitotic
spindle for metaphase so we can even
look a little bit in more detail at the
specific stages of mitosis I love what
you've done with it since I'm working
working with that so we've seen that
phenotype is seen when a cells
undergoing mitosis we have this huge
increase in the cell thickness and this
is actually one of Peters early
publication before I started so I
actually hand over back to you there was
a time before Mukesh as well that seems
a play saitama tryst one of the things
we thought in the very early days we
could look at update is we could look at
cell cycle without staining which we
thought because we know we see a mass
change bond you change with active index
change which is really critical to this
and so we can see just in the two images
here that we can then segment the cells
put them into a dot plot and we can
easily see just by look at the thickness
versus area we can identify our mitotic
cells just as I'd want on a flow
cytometer
and then trace back to those individual
cells which is essentially what this is
really true do these was heaps
bobbington stuff in bubble wrap as an
incubator that's how cool it was but I
just loved applause
to be fair I thought I just love dots
laughter then another your confessionary
at the same time and Marty I like
Smarties but they like Oh class he was a
smarty as well what we can do so we can
start to look at the dividing population
and the mitotic cells are getting done
dividing population but what we want to
do is actually run and I say we want to
look at liberation cell death over
well Paige so in this example here we
have a 5.9 cell be treated them with the
increase in concentration of stylus
boring and you can see what happens to
the mass of the cells so I'm gonna focus
on the two extremes the untreated and
the 10 micromolar Stiles forums and what
we can do is we can quantify the dry
mass of all the cells at each time point
and by doing this we can then a rack of
liberation by the increasing dry mass
over time so you can see that on the top
line of the graph that the dry mass is
increasing in the untreated samples
however with 10 micromolar Stiles boring
what we have is a sudden drop of dry
mass as our cells burst into in the
apoptotic base what we then see is at
loss of the dry mass and lost lots of
the intracellular constituents so that's
great we can report the dry mass and we
can use that to tell us if the cells are
Eric employees they're dying but if they
become static so want to move on to our
next application and okay this is a gap
closure asset or sometimes called
scratching that's thing okay so what I'm
going to do is value the next video and
this is an example of a scratch
screening assay again we take the
multi-well plate approach and we looking
at her control and four and five other
treatments so I'll go ahead and play
this movie and you can see how the
wounds pose
you
accident so if you focused in on the
movie you would be able to see that
different treatments were affecting the
word closure and what I want to show you
here is a matrix that we can generate
from that video so we see at the start
and then we go to the end of the time
map so you can see that the treatment
compound in green you can see that is
inhibiting the rate of good closure so
you want to report that so you can look
at population-based matrix we continue
to start an area of that wound we can
also track the wound area over time and
by planning this we can calculate two
values we can tell you the half-light of
Passau time taken for the woman to close
by 50% we can also report the collective
migration so how fast was that leading
edge moving so you can see it already
that treatment c2 is causing an
inhibition of both the women close
reported by an increase in the half-life
but also in deep least in the collective
migration but for those of you in your
lives you probably saw that the cells
have been segmented on the leading edge
so the leading edge cells are segmented
in red so we can move away from the
population-based matrix or wound ecology
assays and we can directly start to
report we enclosure at a single cell
level so what we're showing in this
graph here is an instantaneous blasty of
those leading get cells in response to
treatments so you can see again
treatment c2 compared to control it's
causing it has a decrease in this B we
can see in treatments b1 and b2 compared
to control have an increase in this T
but there's more to me a migration than
just a speed we want to know the
directionality
so they're not just Christmas
decorations noting that it's too early
so we want to look at another way
another part of multi-team you want to
look at the directionality and most
treatments be one of me to look quite
similar in their cell speed it's only
when we report the directionality that
we can see the differences we can see
now that treatment b1 causes
more other cells to move in a
perpendicular fashion with respective
leading gates protected b2 and to
complete the story the treatment c2
which had an inhibitory effect on wound
closure and a reduction in the sound
speed we can see that reflected in the
migration there's no overall
directionality to these cells so as you
can see we get a lot of informational
really advancing that wound giving us a
so I want to move on next to what we
call a label free dynamic phenotype so
what do I mean by this so let's take
this example we have metastatic breast
cancer cells and on the left in blue we
have them untreated on the right we have
hit them hard with the ten rightmost
Ellsbury and in the middle we have a
tonic stimulation of one animal starts
pouring so we can do our liberation type
of ask them you can look at the dry mass
over time so on the bottom left you can
see that 10 microvolt aspirin causes
that reduction in dry mass as expected
as it sounds done but there's no change
between the control and one animal is
status boring when we look at this
population level after the PhD and I'm
always there for paranoid about all the
data that are generated so I always take
it to an independent machine so we took
this to the live cells cell counter
which if you need to use it so we did
the fixed time points on device and we
saw the same fact we saw that at the
population level there's no difference
between control and one animals that's
boring but remember we had this we've
done this in time-lapse and we watch
these cells all the time so what we're
looking at here now is a top-down view
of the traces left from ourselves over
except to our time-lapse and now is
clearly apparent that something is
happening in the control sample on the
top we can see the cells think quite
close to the point of origin have a1
nanomolar style spoiling what's not
toxic it's changing their behavior we
can see that the cells are moving
further away more sporadically but
that's not all we need to now quantify
this this is great
something put this data into numbers so
again we can run this through the
analysis packages and then we can start
to report this so the first one we have
here is distance by margin plots and we
can see that behavior a nice compact
cell tracks in the control and when we
spread cell tracks in the one animal
house borings we can take that flow
cytometry analysis which is actually
quite useful to quantify behaviors and
what we're plotting here is a cell speed
against nuclear in distance and you can
see the yellow dots move further and
further away from the Indies doctor so
that's showing that one nano Moscow
story is not only making sales move
faster but it also may be further away
from the point of origin and finally we
have a look at some of morphological
metrics we can see on the x-axis here we
have sterility and on the y-axis we have
the meandering index so again the yellow
dots are showing us that the cells
actually have a change in phenotype
they're becoming less variable and
they're moving in a more direct fashion
which is cool the induced winds being
picked up with an endpoint assay we're
just looking at some division because
they look like the proliferating the
same rate but there's subtle things by
putting time as a dynamic dimension and
having the population to look at we've
learned so much more about these
populations to our researchers here and
I'm really moving exploiting this to
look at the subtle characteristic
differences being and why they're
characteristic be different between
different cells sorry anyway so I go on
yes so just to summarize on this slide
you would have missed that information
on a standard and don't response code so
in a standard dose response where we
look at the maximum and effect of the
grip the ic50 ec50 but at the bottom of
the tail of that dose response to these
actually things happening this would
have been 10 and 1 animal style it does
nothing to these deaths
okay so we'll move on to our next and
that final application that we'll
discuss today people mentioned earlier
on in the seminar that we still want
Bresson's without death who still need
to look at these behaviors but we still
want them molecular specificity what's
causing these cells to move faster
change their shape so we need that color
to Bresson's capability so under lighter
we can run a phase and freshman's
prescence image and we can have full
spatial temporal correlation of that
throughout a time that study but what we
want to do is what is drawing at time
lapse you still might want to use we
still might want to use the depressants
imaging but we don't want to image at
the same interval so we don't want to
image who is presses every twenty
minutes cuz then we're back to the same
problem again reintroducing labels but
introduce that toxic dose so in this
next video here what you will see is on
the top part will see the quantitative
phase immune pictures are quite every
twenty minutes and the bottom part of
the the video you'll see the quarantine
for essence and phase image so the
presence was acquired every one hour to
minimize that purpose presence toxicity
so just go ahead and play this video
you
excellent so we saw in that video we can
still performed long-term time-lapse
imaging with Preston Sports minimizing
and the toxic dose of depressant so very
quickly run through the levers in
Hassett there was a reason behind
running that time that's video so in
this experiment here we wanted to call
from genotype to phenotype and so on the
right and we have excels at expressing
the gene and so high in the middle we
have long expression of the gene and on
the Left we have a culture above the
high and low and we want to look at the
phenotype what does this gene do and to
ourselves we can look a proliferation
and we can see that the presence of this
gene reduces the rate of liberation
we can then go on to look at the
morphology so against genotype to
phenotype looking at the morphological
phenotype we can see that the presence
of this gene will increase the area of
the cell produces free State and reduce
the length to width ratio so we are
seeing a morphological phenotype
associated with this gene and then we
look at the tracking so he was able to
track these cells over time and we can
then tell you that the presence of this
gene slows the cells down as well so we
have truly that genotype to phenotype
but the true question in this experiment
was what happens when we mix these cells
back together do they communicate do
they lose their phenotypes at uniqueness
and just like to point out this data was
courtesy of Rob Johnson from UCSF we did
a nice collaboration here using and the
instrument for these data so very
quickly to our final question we had
them cultured in isolation but on the
Left we have put them together we have
the presence metrics so we can get out
the express themselves against some non
expressing cells and then we can analyze
those independently within that code
clubs are really exploring the
heterogeneity and based on the press
this reader and in summary what we see
even in the whole culture we still have
a reduced rate of liberation for the
high expressing cells and also we still
maintain the change in the morphological
and the behavioral phenotype so that
moved into the
of my section of the of the seminar back
to my god say that was a lovely bunch of
segments he just talk through the cash
and I think York is also famous from
again when it comes to these chocolate
oranges York is also famous for where he
was invented he also gives for your
segments and yes I'd love like please
when you've got it ready so actually I'm
going to just very very quickly now just
whirlwind through because I'm not the
scientist that did this work well talk
you through a case study that we've done
here at York itself and this was
actually on prostate cancer research
critically this was done in a
professional and maintenance group and
it's actually Fiona and Amanda that put
a huge amount of effort into here they
trusted these technology from the from
the early days a great deal of faith in
it and they've been rewarded for that
and they they've done some really
remarkable work and actually only going
to show you one bit which I think really
highlights and the importance of
understanding and getting these metrics
out the cells they're really what
they're really good at is using human
patients comes from primary prostate
cancer cell so you don't think about
compared to using normal cell lines
themselves obviously nor so you know
immortal I sell mines are great we can
do loads of research vital point but
primary cells can behave differently and
actually keep you guys doing really good
at revealing the differences in their
behaviors and this is just it you know
if we look at that back piece of
research that they did last year on some
of the primary cells if we look at the
time tracks down near the bottom two
panes it's really good to actually look
at the tracks they behave remarkably
different over the same timeframe
compared to the other cell light
populations that you can see here it's
remarkably different and that's just
shows you how critical it is that even
if using cell lines can have an effect
but using primary cells is great but if
we were then to go and label those
primary cells there's a good chance
we'll return them further normally
extracted going you know we're not
perfect so he's not
but at least we can minimize those
perturbations and that shows just what
difference that can make you can prime
yourselves but why would those prime
yourselves difference why were they
moving differently and certainly we can
look at the area of themselves and you
can see the primary cells are are
significantly larger in cell area
compared to the amount of light cells we
can look at their kinetic features and
then maybe a bit more varied but yeah
it's slightly faster than the other ones
but the mass of the cells was actually
less over time so actually they weren't
proliferating to the same degree
compared to others it's quite a
remarkable set of stats and putting all
that together to give us a unique
phenotype of those primary cells over
other cell so maybe we can use those
other cells if we find the sounds at
have the same fingertip and behaviors we
don't know where all this is going and
so what they've also been able to do is
watch their untreated cells and then use
on the primary cells to program
treatment atoms see how those primary
cells react and we haven't had a
fluorescence to track the sounds over
time to see how they've changed
we haven't accessed News fluorescence
see which ones are differentiated to
differentiate we see different
populations pop up just for the unique
quantitative phase measurements so we
can look at their velocities and far the
meander the round of solvent and the
Amman that we've been eating through
this I think we've probably been getting
around by the way I still haven't got my
segment so you can see even wig MA where
we can see that they are you meeting
their differences and then when we look
at that as a whole population where we
have a bimodal population so we have two
discrete ones you can see when they're
treated they actually split differently
to untreated and we have two different
responders within that population
because the primary cells will behave
differently because they're not just one
cell population they differentiate we
get changes but now we can watch it we
can try and track it we get all that
quantitative information for both
populations that responded positively or
negatively to those drugs so this is
work that PN Amanda in Norman's group
are undergoing at the moment it is just
fantastic work so finally before I leave
you I just want to give you a one
thought I asked you at the start why
microscopy is the most important
technique at that
of us today and I half Joe can be said
about genomics being kind of hitting the
wall proteomic students similar
biochemistry biochemistry class that
maybe had its limitations and that's why
microscopy was ultimately the best
technique out there I'd like to now turn
that on its head
actually I think microscopy is only the
starting point you know now I know that
I have these subpopulations now I know
these all these phenotypic differences
within the cells I now want to go and
look at those individual cells and look
at my genomic dates my transcript what
is transparently dip Dyson and its
sister I've got a negative Dyson sister
what was the difference between the two
and you only see a needle in the
haystack job if I had those two cells
and could look at those on a single-cell
basis I can remove the haystack leaving
me just in needles that made then
difference and behave differently so I
want to now link my cross species breaks
ongoing single cell imaging to single
cell transcriptomics single cell
metabolomic and further not only that
something actually we getting here at
York in the coming months technical
analyst doing digital spatial profiling
system ESP which enables us to really
high multiplex were easily 30 colors so
we can now look at 30 different proteins
or 30 different transcription
transcription mounted at the same time
potentially up to 1,000 different
markers on the tissue at the same time
in one suite so what we can now
hopefully do is move all of these
microscopy techniques so you're going to
be hearing about it's not just us
you've got some other great talks from
other speakers looking at phase imaging
take those images let's start coupling
those two other technologies they're out
there today because actually micro
squeeze at the forefront of the next
revolution or transcription homies the
tableau nice crazy homies it'll get
there once we get there sensitivity and
i/o I just like saying two things
firstly I might say cheers to all of you
listening and putting up with that
garden Matt talk and we this is what
life is like in the lab it's kind of
that's pretty cool
yeah it is okay also it's all my lab
because it's not just for Kesha myself
we've done this but actually there's
people here John far more and I've done
towards its work and all the team
somehow to a greater or lesser extent
are we involved they all support that
work and the groups of health providers
data and of course the importance of all
the sponsors they're actually providing
information please and if you find
looking at my watch right now somewhere
in the world it must be a after another
it must be laughter makes me laugh
straight ok so hopefully you've enjoyed
it see be kinder thank you very much
thank you and you were wonderful
research we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button our speakers will follow up with
questions via email so let's take a look
at some of our viewers questions now
doctors how do you keep cells in focus
over such a long period that's a good
question nothing to be missed completely
is there I do yeah so they're not shy on
to this I can answer this one yeah yeah
okay I'll I'll see if he doesn't he'll
treat well okay goodnight factually and
so when we saw the slide and how we
acquire the data you probably noticed
that we're not connecting an image what
we're collecting is a diffraction
pattern so we know how the light has
scattered and what the sample is cause a
light is scattering that way we can then
with that information we have the
wavefront of how the lights behave to
that diffraction pattern so in the
Fourier domain we can move that way for
it back and forward so we can refocus
the image post-acquisition so that's it
and it's quite an alarming statement
sometimes but after you've acquired the
image we have the data to refocus timing
so in fact there's never a prime at all
because you're your MA
stop the objective drift all the time
but we are always really gaining that
focused post acquisition yeah so I think
the key thing there is we're not dead
stacking there's no we're not removing
the dead stage to do it we take you to
one image and it's a virtual focusing
afterwards the algorithm using space to
refocus that data which is my because it
as as a question by the coin so if your
time lapse in four five six seven days
but most have gone through seven days as
per long time lapse
okay so we've now been Kazan few weeks I
love the fact someone's got enough time
to do two into one experiment I just
think I've got too much time on the
hands that I hope in Christmas we will
get the three weeks critically it does
drift in many other platforms for
fluorescence microscopy and stuff so
with qpi at least we can do that over
time without addicting that's been a big
advantage Dyson that movie at the start
we saw Dyson that was due to click after
a five-day time lapse it's tough so
great question thank you very much our
next question is what resolution can you
achieve hmm that's a spin on each that
depends on the lens it depends on the
numerical aperture the lens that we're
using the movies that you've seen
through this and on the images of
generally being with a very low na ten
times or 20 times lens so they're
actually quite low resolution images but
they don't appear it
I think the resolution limit is probably
up around the 250 300 probably around
300 nanometers in theory if you want to
go better resolution using qpi there's
more talks actually part of this
conference I think it's won by pool park
Tom acute I'll give a quick plug there
cuz actually also working with atomic
you system here at York and that does
get down to equated around one hundred
ten hundred twenty nanometers Botev
resolution on that so that really helps
a resolution and brings it down but
that's not what we were after here we
really after whole cell information and
huge field of view and longitudinal
studies
a lot of the other qpi systems out there
oh great if we zoom into one cell and
sometimes he says why we got the other
system
forgetting that really fast temporal and
spatial resolution information out of it
so the two type of techniques are really
complementary you'll hear more of that
from some of the other speakers
throughout this series thank you for
that and dr. Atul and dr. Suman how many
different samples in our experiment in
one experiment can be untape undertaken
oh okay so actually we can actually can
poly car you alluded to do multi Wells
earlier yeah so you can do up to 96 bar
platforms yes you can do you know yes we
can on the unique way require the data
with typography we can resolve that
meniscus problem so we can now image in
96 bar Bay and we've had user cell three
independent experiments within a 96-well
plate so you can just use that space
there the wells in there is so many
different samples all at the same time
no but big things because you software
with that question you're asking you
know if you want to be image really
really frequently then you're going to
do few more Wells from my perspective a
lot of experiments that we're doing here
I've owned between 6 and 24 wells
because they want that sort of actually
to get more information is beyond what
the experiment needs so actually usually
we can do 24 and get to be replicas
within that 24 well so we're doing
that's what mostly I users are putting
up to 79 seats but very few because
they're just not lookin at drug dose
comparisons in the same way to get a
fine detail bit good to you as possible
thank you thank you gentlemen
would you like to provide our viewers
with any closing remarks well simply if
you've got more questions pops in email
later Mukesh loves them thank you for
listening and I think's giving you ideas
of what you can do you microscopy in the
future and where this fits into the
bigger picture please Lee since the
other presentations is round there's
gonna be some great talks I've seen
lined up so thank you for your time
thanks for your lunch you infect us do
your weekly meal whichever it is
and cheese thank you doctor until dr.
Suman thank you again for your
presentation and your important research
I'd also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand through December
2018 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when the webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye